messieurs dames bonjour je suis très
heureux c'est le troisième épisode de
l'académie des qu'entre les deux
derniers c'était y'a quoi deux ans à peu
près un truc comme ça ça fait mal vous
appréciez beaucoup sur cette chaîne
aujourd'hui la suite y avait pas dit oui
pour hugo et le professeur aujourd'hui
pour jeudi journée non ripley g10 l'aud
aujourd'hui comme dans chaque académie
des camps qui aura 3 ses preuves la
première épreuve est extrêmement simple
on va chacun notre tour être appelé au
tableau pour résoudre un exercice durant
ce passage au tableau on va devoir voler
le plus d'objets possibles présent sur
le bureau du professeur volet c'est à
dire vraiment ça disparaît de la
circulation s'est pas vous la poser sur
votre table c'est vraiment il doit
disparaître mais attention quand vous
ferez quelque chose que je n'ai pas le
droit de faire normalement dans une
salle de classe par exemple parler alors
que vous être si bien sûr vous vous
prendrez un blâme
lorsque vous arriverez à votre troisième
blâme vous serez expulsé du court
jusqu'à la fin de l'épreuve
c'est à dire que votre binôme devra se
débrouiller c'est un homme tout seul pas
cool c'est parti pour la première
épreuve accueillons le professeur on
attend le droff
s'ils n'arrivent pas au bout de cinq
minutes on a moins de partie oui hossa
j'espérais tellement à chaque fois la
dernière seconde il faisait pardon du
retard
juste un petit moment je m'installe
après vous associerez s'asseoir sauf je
plaisante souvent on a mis les pancartes
ma super ça va vous allez faire un petit
serpent vous de votre côté
ça représente quoi un peu j'aime bien en
savoir un peu plus sur les bascules et
je suis scorpions ont dansé savoir
petites fusées directrice tous styles de
musique ouais elon musk j'aime beaucoup
et puis je pense que votre corps à nous
faire rêver donc je le rencontre en est
en tout cas pas sûr mais en tout cas en
tout cas j'aime beaucoup les compliments
vous savez ça je dois souligner à haute
voix doit-on tenue qui est sous
responsable moi je n'ai pu 96 et on va
toujours comme un gant quoi a pris une
ride
la marque select c'est injuste affirme
le succès c'est ma mère qui m'a acheté
mon sac mais ce n'était pas mon idée
d'avoir cet obstacle à l'ouest après si
vous pouvez le changer pour demain par
exemple je pense surtout que tous
plaisir que vous changez de sacs ne
vient pas tout si après on n'est pas là
pour juger mais c'est noté ou pas
monsieur devoir tout et tout est noté
vous savez pas vous à vous apprenez ce
qu'est l'école du coup bas peut-être
peut-être une groupe passe au tableau en
premier parce qu'il a l'air d'avoir soif
d'apprendre
oui très bien plus gobain lui coûte un
peu moins bien ça vous parle le
subjonctif le subjonctif vous regardez
mon livre lago oui non pas bon alors là
c'est un blâme excusez moi non c'est ça
l'important
je n'avais pas compris il regardait mais
très sévère sur le silk way m attendais
un petit instant le dis car mais ça vous
savez que cette zone mais vous ne
l'approchez pas à excuser moi je pensais
qu'on pouvait servir d'un dictionnaire
que j'ai à lomé le sens de la vie je
suis désolé que jiwa ou de blabla pour
le câble a pour nouveau pour le
hugo vous retournez vous asseoir lorenzo
a alors déroulé un petit instant je vais
noter les blâmes ça vous va monsieur
vous êtes un peu technologies comme elon
musk avec votre contre deux bandes
pardon tenez moi main sur moi j'ai
encore des lacunes en anglais vous
pouvez m'écrire bluetooth au tableau non
attendez qu'on va faire c'est que
lorenzo l'aurait mal écrit waouh je
crois qu'ils font des travaux dans le
bâtiment d'à côté et quelque chose est
tombé d'un échafaudage quelque chose est
tombé de l'échafaud sais pas si bien
qu'une pandémie mondiale mais là c'est
quand même choquant ce qui vient de me
tomber dessus tu peux écrire rivière re
attendait bachelot me demande de me
prendre mais c'est en fait c'est
simplement on donne des mots qu'on a sur
lesquels on a des doutes
en terme d'écriture et voilà l élève au
tableau les écrits vous savez ce que ça
jure rivière oui malaisie écrivait
rivière médias les autres élus comme on
écrit venir je pense que l'accent doit
être aiguillés non graves dont 6 ans
après dire ce que vous pouvez nous
montrez vous savez la décomposer le mot
quartile martin vient du latin etc etc
j'aimerais bien vous savez ça non mais
vous vous savez moi je la trouve de tout
enfin je sais vous avez des petits
post-it verger en même temps emprunté 1
s'il vous plaît vous ne mangez vous
consoler les post it they want to go i
go i go staps à l'ex cannois et steve
reich est là c'est stop
hugo vous n'êtes pas à votre place vous
êtes à la place de lorraine ça n'a aucun
sens
mais ces bleus je tiens un prénom qui ne
vous appartenez page vous appelez
lorraine jusqu'à la fin du cours
lucas vous savez ce que c'est ça c'est
une feuille c'est ma feuille à quoi
votre feuille ablaye faye à blâme à
belles âmes et déjà avant d'écrire au
tableau je peux vous dire parce que vous
vous êtes un peu le fil ou de la bande
alors excusez moi le fils ou & 06 ou de
la banque verte s'est passé les nets et
j'ai l'impression c'est très souvent ça
c'est très souvent les garçons il faut
un se lassent malades en leur je n'avais
pas le
jamas mal à tabler sur la smala lorraine
ils étaient houleux c'est çà et là
alors ce mois là elle est bègue c'est un
peu de mousse au piège belgique ou en
allemagne alors n 2 allemagne
c'est bien qu'ils tabassent un tableau à
l'effet notable savourer d'écrire là où
se situe le stylo tenait à non mais là
hiver tu feras car votre voix j'ai
vraiment installer une ia pour ne jamais
plus longtemps j'ai un logiciel pour ça
qu'ils s'appellent le rtx boys et on
peut voit la filtrer séquence travers un
algorithme la voiture ou alors temps de
recul tu sais quoi du bouton comment
derrière alors vous allez m'écrire s'il
vous plaît joindre à l'indicatif jeu et
les bons de secondes aux anneaux déjà
avoir un truc là elle et elle est allée
sur les pieds de kiel ça n'a aucun sens
mais vous savez que c'est votre droit
qui n'ont pas déjà ça va faire un
troisième lame salle hugot up hugo bon
coin on savait déjà
attendez vous voulez que j'appelle vos
parents c'est ça le beaucoup non ça ok
mais là c'est un gros blâme je ne paye
plus au tableau c'est juste que beaucoup
de choses
vous sortez vous sortez internet sortait
on entend la porte claque et voilà mais
je suis vous la voulez me faire pleurer
avant l'exercice suivant les mains selon
jean deuxième lame je vous le dis
regardez le bureau du professeur il n'a
plus d'affaires alors hugo et lorraine
vous arrêter des affaires genre la règle
en bois chlorelle c'est moi qui hausse
le ton ici personne d'autre part dont
hugo monsieur venait merci au co l'ena
oui monsieur le cadeau pour vous la
vacherie 1 2 3 3 blâme ça c'est le coin
oui c'est le coin crise à la zone donné
chaud regardé comme france foot on
transpire c'est humide regardez comme
suspicieux monsieur c'est de la science
il s'est passé quelque chose mais bon
c'est pas pu se passer quelque chose
quoi dans votre enfance oui qu'est ce
qui s'est passé de votre enfance un
professeur que j'affectionnais
énormément j'ai vu des élèves abusé
abusé de son autorité et de ce qu'il
était un prof gentil et ses élèves
ces mêmes élèves rigoler par le musée je
vous coupe je revis mon enfance c'est
terrible on est tous peinés pour comme
les profs j'imagine mais ce que vient de
faire l'ena peiner les pattes c'est un
blâme pour vous parce que vous avez vu
les affaires et dumas mais rien dit je
pensais qu'on était potes mais vous avez
complété bros vous savez où j'en suis là
vous connaissez pas ma vie privée
la prochaine personne
ce qui met sa main ici la voix qui a
fait ça qui a fait ça avec la place du
bourg rue gosselet je vais réussir
maintenant on n'a qu'à mesurer les bras
du go s'ils font plus de 60 centimètres
c'est lui ou emmener votre bravo à 73
dans celui 73 ans certains d'entre vous
me sortez vous apprendrez à ne pas
toucher à mes abonnés nos cartons c'est
presque discriminant s'il est question
est ce qu'on peut compter les points
peut-être de qui a gagné l'épreuve a
donc l'objectif c'était ça en fait non
vous en faites pas vous ne tenez pas
compte comme ça parce que je crois ce
qui se passe bon on a gagné je pense
honnêtement qu'ils ont été meilleurs
qu'eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fief deuxième épreuve rassurez-vous
beaucoup plus explicite
nous allons être en examen tous les
quatre concentrer sur notre contrôle
donc on sera plongé dans le silence et
freddy lui sera dans ses notes j'ai ici
un détecteur de décibels il va falloir
faire le plus gros bruit possible si le
prof gris qui a fait le bruit ce n'est
pas comptabilisé on n'a qu'à le prof
vous savez qu'on vous ait entendu dans
toutes les classes à côté on m'a demandé
d'être plus ferme du ferme la chanson de
la fouine
moi j'ai envie de chanter avec vous mais
vous m'avez saouler vous avez touché une
faille en silo tous très bien les bons
élèves
notez le l e déjà joe dante savait pas
de faute le doute est il une faiblesse
et on a combien de temps pour répondre à
cette problématique
moi c'est un pas 30 mois pas sympa parce
que je dois serrer la vis ces 20 minutes
c'est dommage c'est marrant parce que
dommage ça rime avec chômage c'est parti
[Musique]
ou là mais comme à l'aller n'a vous
sortez c'était toi qu'est-ce que cézanne
excusez moi je suis à côté d'elle
c'était pas les noms c'est le chantier à
côté
silence maintenant et je veux plus
entendre ces bruits là ça n'a aucun sens
[Musique]
il m'a fait trop tourner ou lucas je
suis le gars ça m'a traversé irene khan
à vouloir bosser et il a vachement
avancé en plus je veux écrire les
martiens ils ont écrit des phases
j'ai connu un seul et je te revoir
monsieur je lance des pétards je voulus
ravaux autres qu'il a écrit lucas le
doute est il une faiblesse c'est très
bien c'est un très bon titre
ensuite il a écrit je pense que non
point il se trouve que j'aime bien la
vie de nous deux ça ne veut rien dire je
te vois votre trousse may be a remercié
vous rend ça oui non c'est sale
autorités je fais ce que je veux ça
c'est quoi c'est pas comme si on fait le
nom mais en fait c'étaient ses recettes
lui elle dit je sais pas c'est quoi les
y voilà
c'est des boulettes de brouillon de
feuilles a4 quand j'étais morte
voilà ce qui se passe vous me poussez à
moi je m'en bats les couilles de mon job
non et vous le dis c'est pas comment
vous allez rattraper ça
[Musique]
cactus qui dans ce système on peut
l'écouter ce cactus ces termes ou non je
suis désolé il ya quoi bon pied la lucas
enermax n'ont levé voulez-vous lebouc
apam élevé ou le quartier
je veux bien ça c'est possible d'acheter
un cactus qui chantent mais ensuite
votre pied ici sont là tant qu'on y est
on est claquettes chacun s'habille comme
il veut et fait ce qu'il veut c'est vrai
donc si mes chaussures sur un peu trop
classique pour vous on peut entendre le
bruit
aulas lors le talonnait temps faire
c'est bien de juger le style voyez bien
qu'ils se passe des choses non mais
vraiment fait un truc vous pensez quoi
de ses chaussures non moi je ne trouve
pas la bonne en tout cas c'est non
seulement aux dieux et ça fait bien trop
de bruit vous savez quoi le cas vous
allez me montrer comment on fait des
claquettes malaisie elle doit elle aller
sur la scène avait il alors dit oui en
fait et on va vous applaudir
ironiquement voilà sur les faits les
applaudir
c'était nul à chier moi j'ai envie qu'on
s'entende bien qu'à vous sentez vous
allez faire des claquettes dans la cour
à les y voilà vous prêt le malin vous
allez séduire des filles comme ça mais
le chômage c'est ça qui vous attendra
derrière l'ena boulanger à l'ailé la
bourgeoisie allez les verts mais voyez
bien elle est partie avec un jouet qui
faisait du bruit
vous êtes mes préférés les boulistes que
j'ai vu ce que j'ai fait le doute s'est
osé sortir des idéologies de l'entendre
hugo ok moi j'ai marqué par définition
le doute est un sentiment proche de
l'hésitation
c'est vrai monsieur vous connaissez
monsieur bah moi dit rien et c'est du
web
ouais bah voila je voulais d'aidé à
l'egypte a besoin de me faire un petit
ruisseau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je comprends pas ce que vous faites pour
être un espace qu'il allait tomber donc
dingue
il avait encore des pétards dans leur cv
encore des lacs sortez sortez tout fermé
la porte
voilà on a un an vous avez vu c'est
passé pour le jour à huy sont
incorrigibles comme a dit ça tombe bien
vous allez voir ça tombe bien j'autorise
l'ena et squeeze à retourner avec une
faute pour en cours car ils n'ont rien
fait du tout ps merci de m'envoyer
lorraine et hugo pour un pour un bilan
de discipline en faire un petit truc
pour moi c'est vraiment celle elle est
habillée comme moi aujourd'hui c'est
quoi ça on n'est pas derrière ça hugo
lorraine
regardez ce que fait l'udc a fait comme
lucas mais écrivait quelque chose de
cohérent pas comme il l'a fait mais
sinon dans la gestion c'est exactement
ça silence maintenant s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
ça s'est très mal an très malin là c'est
trop vous dépasser michael voir ça veut
dire que non seulement vous avez des
pétards mais vous avez dû se rabattent
artu fume sorte et je sais très bien que
c'est vous vous êtes le petit fou fou
jadis qualifié là et vous me donnez un
bonbon on peut ramener les bonbons
encore là qu'on dise calais est une
disqualification
là on perd alors qu'on vous a battu 2 à
0 sur toutes les preuves des claques
balance va te fait rire à chaque fois
n'était pas de la chance que je passe un
bon bon bon bon c'était dangereux je me
souvenais pas qu'un pétard c'est ça non
attention chez vous achetez pas de peta
très mauvaise idée
disqualification mérité mais 1 partout
un manque de discrétion quand même assez
on peut parler de votre voiture
troisième épreuve nous allons devoir
préparer un exposé et pas des moindres
on aura chacun une thématique différente
évidemment et ensuite on aura 20 minutes
pour le préparer et quand je dis
préparer un exposé évidemment c est le
sujet et par et là l'illustration via un
merveilleux powerpoint et c'est le
professeur qui donnera une note à chaque
binôme voilà l'impressionnante mais
avant sa remise des sujets
vos sujets les plus hauts sommets de
russie new way et ineo j'ai la
reproduction des coquillages et des
crustacés non c'est non l'aveu la
crustacés au franchement on est les plus
hauts sommets de la russie bouh pays
c'est la première fois depuis dix ans et
la page et tiësto logiciel on inverse
ok la problématique ça va être si je vis
dans quelle mesure ces que la
reproduction des crustacés et
différentes des nôtres
ok on va surfer sur fécamp a priori les
bras du goût un bras du goal on a mesuré
un tout à l'heure c'est bien celle là
j'ai l'impression que c'est des années
d'études qui deviennent ici
[Musique]
il ya plus ban quoi japon ont fait un
exposé de m on va les explose
en plus je sais que freddy va être y va
et honnête tu vois ce que je veux dire
vous allez voir ce que ça donne
là bas
oui on s'est enfermés pour la blague ça
va on a quasiment que huawei
j'adore là on a soigné le travaille pas
je sens bien mon aile bruce lp/o 5462
sait qui c'est qui la loa comment ça va
moi les élèves
tout se passe bien connaissez-vous le
client mais ce qu'on y voit évidemment
je perds mais je vous donne des petits
type the lemon pas aux autres c'est bon
c'est bon on les a merci me rappelle
c'est que je n'ai pas de temps qu'un
débat qui revient à les aider les autres
perdez pas de temps des gitans si jamais
non non vous en faites partie ajoute
cheikh après quoi sert présenterait pas
on est prêt à faire exploser
vous adorez toucher les épaules pas du
tout excusez moi mais je reconnais
l'avenir de court alors dans tous les
deux dernières haies après les bébés
quand il est peut-être
or la poste et nick mallet pas un
powerpoint et drôle c'est de passer très
bien très bien vous avez l'air très fier
de gourdes nancéen trop bien fonctionné
a éclaté nous laisserons faire un petit
minet jeu pour voir qu'est passe en
premier voulait faire un pierre feuille
ciseaux de loin là où vous êtes l'a23
hockey premier bonjour monsieur bonjour
vous et nous et nous nous tu fais un
anneau bonjour à vous aussi bonjour à
tous merci merci d'être là salut c'est
hugo et comme chaque semaine on est
parti pour un nouvel exposé pour
commencer aujourd'hui on va donc parler
d'un reproduction des coquillages et des
crustacés
waouh un travail de recherche de longue
haleine petite introduction
qu'est ce qui s'est passé les
coquillages et crustacés quelqu'un veut
peut-être c'est un exposé qui est
participatif dont vous pouvez tous
prendre la parole se rendre par aussi à
exposer ce volet wii c'est sur la plage
eh oui donc ce sont donc des des
éléments qui vivent essentiellement des
éléments marins qui vont vivre donc près
de la mer ou alors voilà sur sur la
plage
en général vous en avait quelques-uns
justice y voyez le fameux ces belles
sommes pas tous d'un homme plus
communément appelée huîtres la question
c'est la suivante les transitions dans
quelle mesure la reproduction des
crustacés et similaires ou non à celle
de nous les humains un machin mais
j'imagine et crustacés qu'est ce que
noah commence juste au cours du congrès
c'est ce genre de réflexion qu'on va
essayer d'avoir ici y at il des sites de
rencontres pour coquillages et crustacés
par exemple j'ai même entendu parler
lors de nos recherches d'une limace de
mer au pénis jetables qui après chaque
accouplement qui dure environ combien
temps l'accouplement de la limace tas de
merde xvi exactement quelques dizaines
de secondes
c'est plutôt efficace et alexa et bien
s'être limaces de mer va se débarrasser
de ce sont donc voir entre autres
informations que vous voulez peut-être
sur les sur les crustacés et coquillages
on sait toujours pas comment ils
s'accouplent finalement s'y jettent leur
pénis mais ça c'est un exemple d'un truc
excentré besoin
les moules sachez que des moules vivent
en colonies or en colonie il n'y a pas
de vie privée dans le cas des mots mais
y'a des moniteurs elles s'accouplent au
milieu tout le monde elles se font face
elles font base bébé eh bien on avait un
temps limité pour cet exposé alors déjà
bravo parce que là j'ai appris plein de
choses
c'était riche merci solide et c'est no
mé nal
c'est un fcpr alaïa du le battre je sais
pas ce que vous allez faire franchement
j'ai été bluffé je pensais pas en faire
on fait quoi cet été messieurs dames
vous allez bien ça va ça va ce binôme
existe et il est là pour vous parler des
plus hauts sommets de russie une
question tout fait quand je dis russie
vous dit poutine poutine vodka c'est
gagner 1.1.1 peut l'applaudir
mais c'est pas tout quand j'ai aussi
vous dit poutine s'était raté moscou
quand j'ai aussi vous dit poutine s'est
gagnée mais j'adore ça
celui qui vient de sceller la tout
gagner quand j'ai réussi vous dites ours
poutine dans un sit in a way ont souvent
personnes à plus de ses portes avant de
parler des plus hauts sommets de russie
le bh vous connaissez tous le m vous
connaissez tous le kilomètre ouais le bh
c'est une nouvelle unité de mesure créée
par elon musk est très utilisé dans la
création des fusées space x vous de
connaître good j'adore ce v6 le bh c'est
tout simplement le bras du corps un bras
du gauche égalent 62 cm les plus hauts
sommets de russie en troisième position
c'est donc le client chase co et que
tout le monde connaît bien sûr claude
tout ce qu on a eu des témoignages de
divers api nice quand ils sont là haut
ils savent pas vraiment où ils disent
bon bah c'est l'unité en maître mais moi
j'ai plus le ressenti des tas 4009 mais
est ce que je veux dire d'unités absolue
c'est celle ci ça fait 6597
brad hugo c'est un secret c'est très
personnes dorénavant le deuxième plus
haut sommet de russie le dic tôt à ne
pas confondre avec dictaphone ou texté
la dictée ou un dicton 5205 m hélas
alors là on a des témoignages qui nous
disent mais je comprends pas j'ai
l'impression d'être assis 1800 m combien
de brett d'hugo ça fait 7229 bras du
beau pour le deuxième plus gros le plus
haut sommet russe le mot elbrouz la
hauteur du mont elbrouz andrade hugo c
7636 bh mais la plus grande montagne
russe du monde cm conduire x ou le
tonnerre de zeus selon c'est un tonnerre
d espoir ça veut dire pardon parce que
nous on applaudit la tutelle et bien
c'est marrant si j'avais pas applaudi je
me serais pas reconnu là dedans mais là
je pense que je fais rien je m'écoutais
bien j'ai passé un vrai
genre je ne suis pas amusé comme ça
depuis belle lurette l'été dernier je
pense depuis le lycée descartes a donc
déjà bravo et vous pouvez vous applaudir
mutuellement on a vraiment de type
d'excusé vraiment différent ouais c'est
vrai parce que déjà en direction
artistique
on a quelque chose de très saint nom de
votre côté c'est vrai on a vu allons à
l'essentiel est là entre un truc plus
fou c'est elle le savait quoi on a trois
points
la prestance parce que certes le projet
vous nous montrez est intéressant mais
si vous êtes comme ça oui bah la viande
et à la direction artistique et
l'information je sais toujours pas
comment les coquillages basso l'internet
ou par les assauts le point de lens aux
côtés russie le point de la dea
ils ont le prendre avant moi j'ai été
bluffé par les transitions parlé c'était
super super moi j'aimerais que tout le
monde puisse le voir
et maintenant le dernier point la
prestance et la prestance il y avait de
part et d'autre de belles attitudes
il y avait des gestuelles qui était
cohérente et je pense que maintenant
vous êtes capable de distinguer une
huître d'un bigorneau c'est très vrai
qu'est-ce que ça à voir avec la
prestance je sais pas trop je faisais
avait l'impression qu'elle avait pris en
otage savais pas comment m'en sortir
j'aimerais qu'il n'y ait pas de
vainqueur et vous devez tous vainqueurs
mais mais mais mais mais mais mais mais
mais on va devoir choisir quelqu'un
lucas
hélas
lauren hugo
pour la présentation il ya quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup touché c'était le côté
très participatif
de votre équipe vous êtes dans le coeur
c'est un jouet c'est ciao ciao ciao ciao
voilà bien joué c'est ça que j'aime
c'est ce que je veux maintenant lorraine
jour le jour l'aurait alors elle mettait
pas des crampes aux jambes aggravent
leurs ailes c'est pas grave vous jure
regarder mais pour ça s'est joué à je
peux voir monop quasiment rien je me
fais chier pendant la pré non c'était un
très bon moment passé à vos côtés la
compétition fut rude freddy tu es un
incroyable professeur m'a donné envie
d'apprendre cela par dessus tout sécher
les cours
moi je vous remercie d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo on était plus dissipés que
jamais sur vous a quand même réussi à
bien vivre ça au montage lena tu le
donnes envie de jouer avec je ne remets
toujours pas des pétards contre
n'hésitez pas à passer voir évidemment
le instagram et la chaîne youtube du
coup pour avoir des news dans tous les
sens plus sérieuse que l'exposé sérieuse
et vous avez vu il s'exprime bien même
pour des blagues s'exprime
redoutablement bien n'hésitez pas à
passer voir leurs stars g de lorraine
l'ena -elle ce qu'on est ce qu'on
présente lennar aller voir sa chaîne
youtube ces réseaux tous les natifs est
beaucoup plus longue oui pourquoi je
fasse on veut promo chez pas j'ai adoré
j'ai envie de voir là de parler de vous
parce que je vous aime et freddy homme
le plus drôle d'instagram oui d'après le
comité officiel des gens drôles
d'instagram acheter mais libre et à
bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo sur grand merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]